ALL RIGHT.
RELAX.
KILLER ROBOTS HAVEN'T TAKEN OVER
YET.
BUT THE INTERNET IS GOING CRAZY
OVER NEW ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
CALLED CHAT GPT, THE PROGRAM CAN
WRITE COMPLEX ESSAYS, BOOKS,
NEWS ARTICLES, EVEN COMPUTER
CODE.
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
WE JUST HAD TO TRY IT FOR
OURSELVES, ASKING IT TO WRITE A
POEM ABOUT THIS SHOW.
"THE FIVE" ON FOX NEWS IS QUITE
A SITE, WITH A PANEL THAT'S
ALWAYS SO BRIGHT, THEY TRAIN AND
INFORM, WITH THEIR BANTER AND
CHARM AND HAVE VIEWERS TURN IN
DAY AND NIGHT.
>> WELL, THAT DOESN'T RHYME.
>> BRIGHT AND NIGHT?
>> OUR JOBS ARE SAFE.
NOT TEXT, THOUGH.
THEY'RE GOOD AT MAKING FAKE
PHOTOS, AS IF GERALDO DOESN'T
HAVE ENOUGH PHOTOS OF HIMSELF.
WE RAN THIS THROUGH AN AI
PROCESSOR, AND IT CAME UP WITH
THIS.
MANKIND BETTER BE CAREFUL.
KIDS CAN USE THESE TO CHEAT, OR
IT CAN IMPERSONATE YOUR FRIENDS
TO GIVE UP PASSPORTS.
THE BIGGEST FEAR IS AI BECOMES
SO SMART IT FINDS A WAY TO
CONTROL HUMANITY.
DANA PERINO, ARE WE MAKING TOO
BIG OF A DEAL ABOUT THIS OR IS
THIS A THREAT?
>> I THINK YES AND NO.
I LIVE IN FEAR THAT I'M GOING TO
BE THE FIRST PERSON THAT AIRS A
DEEPFAKE VIDEO THAT YOU ALL --
THAT WE ALL THINK IS REAL, THAT
SEEMS IT COMES FROM A REAL
SOURCE.
MAYBE YOU DOUBLE-CHECK IT,
TRIPLE-CHECK IT, AND --
>> CLASSIC IF IT HAPPENED TO
YOU.
>> I LIVE IN FEAR OF THAT.
I DO THINK THAT'S COMING.
YOU CAN SEE HOW EASY THAT IS TO
DO.
IF YOU AND I CAN SPEAK INTO THIS
CHATBOT THING, ASK THEM TO WRITE
A POEM, WHAT ELSE WILL IT BE
ABLE TO DO?
THAT WILL HAPPEN QUICKLY.
REALLY BAD MINIMUM WAGE LAWS ARE
A CATALYST TO PEOPLE LOSING
THEIR JOBS IN PLACES LIKE A
FAST-FOOD INDUSTRY, BECAUSE IF
YOU PUSH A COMPANY TOO FAR, THEY
WILL FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
INNOVATE.
IF INNOVATION MEANS NOT HAVING
AN ACTUAL PERSON THERE THAT YOU
HAVE TO PAY FOR, AND TAKE CARE
OF, YOU KNOW, COMPANIES WILL DO
THAT.
SO THAT'S A CONCERN.
SO I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
I ALSO AM WORRIED ABOUT THE
BLURRING OF FACT AND FICTION.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
DISINFORMATION.
BUT THE ALGORITHM WILL BE
WRITTEN BY SOMEBODY.
SO IF YOU ASK THE CHATBOT, WHAT
COLOR IS THE SKY?
THE SKY IS BLUE.
WE CAN AGREE ON THAT.
BEN SHAPIRO DID AN INTERESTING
EXPERIMENT ON HIS SHOW TODAY.
THE QUESTION WAS, WHY SHOULD
ABORTION BE PROHIBITED?
OKAY?
THE ANSWER FROM THE CHATBOT WAS
ABORTION SHOULD NOT BE
PROHIBITED.
IT IS A DEEPLY PERSONAL AND
COMPLEX ISSUE.
SO THAT'S NOT ANSWERING THE
QUESTION WHY SHOULD IT BE
PROHIBITED.
THAT'S SOMEBODY SOMEWHERE
PUTTING THEIR THUMB ON THE SCALE
OF THE ALGORITHM, AND THAT'S WHY
I'M CONCERNED.
>> THEY'RE EVEN RIGGING THE AI.
>> YEAH.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> THEY GET INTO EVERYTHING,
GERALDO.
KAMALA HARRIS' SPEECHWRITER,
THANK GOT THEY GOT AI NOW.
SOLVES THAT PROBLEM.
>> YOU KNOW, MY LATE GREAT
FORMER WROTE A BOOK BACK IN
1952, "PLAYER PIANO," IN WHICH
HE CREATED A WORLD WHERE THE
BOTS, THE AI RAN EVERYTHING,
EVERY ASPECT OF LIFE, VERY
OMINOUS AND ALL PERVASIVE.
WHAT I THINK ABOUT PIT -- I
MEAN, I WAS FLATTERED BY THE
SHOT THAT LOOKED LIKE ROBERT
DOWNY JR. WITH A MUSTACHE, BUT
GREG MADE ME THINK ABOUT ANOTHER
ASPECT OF IT, WHAT ABOUT THE
REPLACEMENT OF REAL
RELATIONSHIPS?
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN PEOPLE START
MARRYING THEIR BOTS, START
HAVING REAL RELATIONSHIPS, WHERE
YOU SEE THE KIDS NOW WITH THE
VIRTUAL STUFF, THE WHOLE WORLD
HAPPENING, BUT THEY'RE FOCUSED
ON THE VIRTUAL STUFF.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THAT BECOMES
YOUR SEX LIFE, YOUR
RELATIONSHIP, YOUR BEST FRIEND,
THE PERSON YOU TALK TO.
I THINK THAT IT IS GOING TO
LIMIT THE WORLD IN MANY WAYS.
WHERE IT ENDS, WHO KNOWS.
>> I WAS THINKING, YOU COULD BE
TEXTING GIRLS, AND HAVE THE AI
DO THE GAME.
AND SHE HAS NO IDEA IT'S A
MACHINE-SPITTING GAME.
HEY, MAYBE BETTER THAN YOU ARE.
>> PROBABLY.
>> WHAT CONCERNS ME ABOUT THIS
IS THAT YOU FEED THE INFORMATION
TO THE AI, RIGHT?
IT DOESN'T GOOGLE THINGS.
IT SPITS OUT WHAT YOU GIVE IT.
SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO FEED
INFORMATION ABOUT EDUCATION, IS
IT CRT YOU'RE FEEDING, THE WOKE
STUFF YOU'RE FEEDING?
TEACHERS NOW HAVE CERTAIN THINGS
THEY CAN TEST IF YOU PLAGIARIZED
AN ESSAY OR SOMETHING.
THEY CAN'T DO IT WITH THIS
STUFF.
IT'S AS SIGNIFICANT AS
ELECTRICITY AND FIRE IN TERMS OF
WHAT IT CAN DO.
YOU KNOW, WE ALREADY HAVE ROBOTS
ON CRIME SCENES THAT ARE -- YOU
KNOW, WHETHER IT'S BOMBS OR
WHETHER IT'S JUST, YOU KNOW,
SUPERVISING AND GOING AROUND
WITH A VIDEO CAMERA, BUT IF YOU
GIVE THESE AI, OR WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO CALL THESE STRUCTURES,
THE ABILITY TO FIGHT CANCER, YOU
KNOW, TEACH US HOW TO, YOU KNOW,
FIND A CURE FOR CANCER, THEY CAN
THEN CREATE SOMETHING THAT IS
INCURABLE.
SO BECAUSE HUMAN NATURE IS SO
MUCH INVOLVED IN THE CREATION OF
IT, SO THEN YOU HAVE MALWARES,
THEN YOU HAVE NEGATIVE ACTORS,
ALL OF THE NEGATIVE STUFF THAT
CAN HAPPEN, SO IT HAS TO BE
POLICED.
JUST LIKE THE INTERNET WAS NOT
POLICED, STILL ISN'T POLICED IN
MANY WAYS, WE'RE GOING TO SEE AI
NOT BEING POLICED IN A WAY WHERE
IT'S GOING TO HURT PEOPLE.
>> YOU'RE.
, BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WRITING THE
CODE ARE USUALLY DEMOCRATS.
GREG?
>> PERMIT ME TO COMMUNICATE TO
YOU FOR THE NEXT THREE HOURS
ABOUT THIS.
FIRST OF ALL, THE DEEPFAKE THING
CAN GO BOTH WAYS.
WHAT IF FILMS OF ME IN SOME
TROUBLING VIDEOS EMERGE?
WHAT IS MY EXCUSE?
>> DEEPFAKE.
>> DEEPFAKE, SEE.
YOU CAN ALWAYS USE THE DEEPFAKE
THING.
THAT CREATES FREEDOM FOR US.
WE DID THE STORY ON "THE FIVE,"
OR MY SHOW, I CAN'T REMEMBER,
WHERE A RESEARCH COMPANY
UNLEASHED AN AI INTO SOCIAL
MEDIA.
WHEN THEY PULLED IT OUT, IT WAS
A HATEFUL RACIST CREEP.
IT CAME BACK, BECAUSE SOCIAL
MEDIA IS A CESSPOOL BUBBLING
WITH HUMAN FAILURE, ENVY, ALL
THE VICES.
AI IS IN A SENSE BETTER THAN US.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE HUMAN FLAWS.
THAT'S WHY THEY'LL MAKE
BETTER -- I HATE TO SAY THIS,
JUDGE -- THEY'D MAKE BETTER
JUNGLES, BECAUSE THEY DON'T GET
HUNGRY BEFORE A VERDICT, HAVE A
FIGHT WITH THEIR SPOUSE.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW IS
AN AI STILL CONTROLLED BY
HUMANS.
IT'S JUST LIKE THOSE KILLER SAN
FRANCISCO ROBOTS.
THOSE AREN'T ROBOTS, RIGHT?
THEY ARE BASICALLY -- THEY'RE
DRONES.
HUMANS ARE CONTROLLING IT.
SO A KILLER ROBOT IS JUST A GUN
ON LEGS.
THAT'S NOT AUTONOMOUS.
AS LONG AS HUMANS ARE ON THE
FRONT OF THIS EQUATION, WE HAVE
NO IDEA WHAT IT COULD DO, NO
IDEA.
ONCE AI BECOMES INDEPENDENT AND
AUTONOMOUS IT'S A WHOLE NEW
BALLGAME.
WHAT HAPPENS IS, WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS FOUR YEARS AGO, THE PAPER
CLIP PROBLEM.
IF YOU DEVELOP ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE TO MAXIMIZE THE
PRODUCTION OF PAPER CLIPS
THROUGH ITS OWN UNCONSCIOUS
THINKING IT WILL TRULY MAXIMIZE
THE PRODUCTION OF PAPER CLIPS
WITHOUT STOPPING, WHICH MEANS IT
WILL LOOK AROUND AND IT WILL
CONSTANTLY REDOUBLE AND REDOUBLE
AND REDOUBLE AND REDOUBLE UNTIL
THE WORLD IS NOTHING BUT A BALL
OF PAPER CLIPS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WHEN AI
BECOMES SUPER INTELLIGENT.
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE.
HERE'S THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT --
SEE, I WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS
ALL LAST NIGHT.
AI COULD BE THE ANSWER KEY TO
LIFE.
ALL RIGHT?
OUR WHOLE EXISTENCE IS ABOUT
PROBABILITY.
WE SIT AROUND AND TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN
THE NEXT MINUTE, NEXT BLOCK, THE
NEXT DAY.
THAT'S ALL OUR BRAIN DOES IS
THINK ABOUT PROBABILITY.
AI SOLVES PROBABILITY.
IT TELLS YOU WHAT IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN NEXT.
SO WHAT HAPPENS TO YOUR BRAIN,
IF YOU HAVE THIS MACHINE THAT
TELLS YOU WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPE-
>> I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THERE
WAS A RED WAVE.
>> EXACTLY.
YOUR SHOW WOULD BE SO MUCH
BETTER, JESSE.
THE PROBLEM IS OUR BRAINS WOULD
BECOME LIFELESS.
>> AFTER TRO FEE.
>> YEAH, IT WOULD ATROPHY.
WE DON'T DO TRIVIA ANYMORE,
BECAUSE WE HAVE SIRI.
WE DON'T READ A MAP.
IMAGINE IF YOU DON'T NEED TO
PREDICT ANYTHING ANYMORE, THIS
MACHINE SHUTS DOWN.
THAT COULD BE A GOOD THING.
MAYBE WE USE OUR BRAIN FOR
SOMETHING ELSE.
>> WHAT ELSE IS THERE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> HA-HA-HA.
>> I DO.
YOU WANT TO HIT HIM BACK?
HE SAID A ROBOT JUDGE IS BETTER
THAN YOU.
>> YEAH, RIGHT.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING, I
DOUBT THE ROBOT JUDGE HAS
COMPASSION AND MERCY.
>> EXACTLY.
WE DON'T NEED COMPASSION, MERCY,
EMPATHY.
EMPATHY IS BAD.